the case against kyle rittenhouse the
teenager who shot leftist rioters that
had been threatening him during the blm
attacks last summer has been gradually
collapsing since the trial
began
and yesterday one of the leftists who
was actually shot by rittenhouse
may have put the final nail in the
case's coffin
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
and he fired right
correct oh [ __ ] that's it
that's it
directing verdict directed verdict on
all the murder charges kyle knows
directed verdict on the murder charges
he just he just exhaled
kyle oh he looks like he's gonna cry
how do you not
how do you
how do you not acquit after that
look
you know testimony is not going the way
the state wanted when one of the
prosecuting attorneys ends the
questioning with his head in his hands
kyle rittenhouse was obviously acting in
self-defense given what we heard
yesterday not only should he not be
convicted he shouldn't even have been
charged but rittenhouse's crime has
nothing to do with guns or homicide
if he had different colored skin or
different political views
the elite in this country would be
calling for him to walk
rittenhouse is real crime oh it's one of
the worst crimes of all
it's being a right wing white guy i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from m4 who says
listening to this show in school because
i learned more from this guy than my lib
teachers thank goodness i'm a senior and
leaving this year well i'm very honored
i am very honored to be subverting
america's educational institutions from
the inside from the inside of earbuds
that you're listening to in class the
new york times is
lying about what happened yesterday at
the trial by the way just so you know if
you're reading cnn or the new york times
or whatever there was a tweet that went
out from julie bozeman from the new york
times says quote gross croots he was the
the guy testifying he was the guy who
had been shot by kyle rittenhouse gross
croots a paramedic from west allis a
milwaukee suburb was shot in the arm by
written house gross croots was holding a
handgun pointed in the air when
rittenhouse shot him from a short
distance away
julie boseman from the new york times
sent out that tweet
after
yesterday's testimony
so after she knew it was bogus
she sends out that tweet
then
this guy testifies and says no he i was
pointing the gun at him and that's the
only time he shot eventually she deleted
the tweet but the media are really
really desperate to portray kyle
rittenhouse as a white supremacist
right wing white suprema no he was a guy
acting in self-defense while blm and
antifa burned down not just his city but
the country and why were they rioting
they were rioting because police rightly
shot someone named jacob blake who had
just sexually assaulted a woman was
driving off with her kids but the media
and the left took his side jacob blake's
side because their anti-cop because
white people bad black people good
because right winger is bad left winger
is good because cops bad criminals good
because because they have a narrative in
mind that they're going to push
and kyle rittenhouse fit the narrative
of the bad guy and the problem is the
facts on the ground completely
contradict their narrative
because kyle ridden house from
everything we know about this case was
acting in self-defense they should call
it call it a day now the prosecuting
attorney should just walk off the job
say you know what
sorry we tried see you and let
rittenhouse off the hook
speaking of
racism or alleged racism or perceived
racism
transportation secretary pete budajed
he's back from his his like 17 years of
paternity leave he is
now back on the job
and he is taking on the big problems
namely
all the structural racism
of bridges and highways
can you give us
the construct of how you will
deconstruct the racism that was built
into the roadways that you talked to the
griot earlier when you broke that
information with us can you talk to us
about how that could be deconstructed
for sure yeah so the principle of
justice 40 is that at least 40 percent
of the clean investments in this bill
will go to benefit the communities that
are over burned and overburdened and
underserved so part one of that is
defining those those investments that
are eligible and that's a lot of it and
we're working to map out kind of program
by program mode by mode uh what would
qualify for example if we're uh buying
clean buses right how do we make sure in
terms of where those buses go but also
looking at the business opportunity the
jobs that are going to be created the
businesses that that will have a chance
to compete
for for the business opportunities it
creates that too i think is a very
important element of equity here that's
in the spirit of justice 40. and again
we have a lot of guidance and oversight
from the white house since that's an
administration-wide initiative
we know that we've got to build our own
internal uh kind of ways of of uh
aligning and defining that inside the
administration
can anybody translate that into english
for me because i you know i consider
myself fairly capable with the english
language i have no idea what he just
said
actually i i know
i know what he didn't say
okay i know what he's dancing around
he's like the kid who shows up to class
without doing the reading he is i don't
whatever he's saying about the roads and
the bridges it really doesn't matter the
reason i bring up this clip is because
pete buttige is the perfect
representative
of
one of the biggest problems
in facing our society today namely bs
okay he's a bs artist is what he is he
because he's very intelligent he's very
intelligent you can't deny the guy and
he's smooth and he's a quick talker and
he smiles and he's really nice but he's
a bs artist
and these guys tend to do really well i
think i think pete went to harvard
or he went to some fancy schools and he
he worked in consulting which is the
most bs industry there is and he it's
like a scam on corporate america if you
ask me
feet voted judge has been trained his
whole life
to just give the appearance of substance
give the appearance that he's saying
something without saying anything at all
and you hear it all the time in all the
bogus ideological classes like i don't
know urban studies or ethnicity and
migration or gender studies or all the
studies classes and in consulting well
you know first what we're going to do is
we're going to study equity and we're
going to make sure that there's synergy
between the different departments and
and what's really important is we want
to make sure that our resources are
going to the underserved and the places
where they're not overserved they're
underserved and so it's going to be just
and what it's really about is equitable
and it's about the transfer and it's
about growth and synergy
thank you for listening to my
presentation what about he doesn't even
what he doesn't even answer the question
and what was the question the question
how are you going to deconstruct the the
racism that was constructed and you got
it so you're going to deconstruct and
de-layer and and you're going to through
critical and
it's all just bogus hey buddy fix the
roads how about that fix the roads deal
with the supply chain crisis
that's isn't that the bare minimum of
what the transportation secretary is
supposed to do make sure that things are
capable of being transported i don't
know what it's well you can't do that
because we're all just high on our own
fumes of absolute
bs in this country and so the we can all
talk pie in the sky really really well
about climate change and the metaverse
and the systemic structural racism but
the basic elements of our society are
crumbling our roads literally crumbling
our highways and our bridges literally
crumbling our elections crumbling we
don't have faith in those anymore our
basic institutions crumbling all of that
is falling apart
because we're all focused on this pie in
the sky nonsense
speaking of transportation by the way
an update to that race in new jersey
where a truck driver who spent a very
little amount of money
on his entire campaign beat the most
powerful democrat in the legislature
so this guy
edward durr
beat the top-ranking new jersey democrat
lawmaker
steve sweeney president of the new
jersey state senate
but
sweeney won't won't concede he says
we've got to count every vote and he
just found
thousands
of previously undiscovered ballots
i don't know where they were they must
have been hiding under a bed somewhere
or something so he found these ballots
and he wants to make sure that every
every ballot is counted
uh this is
very on brand for new jersey to have
this transparent sort of corruption
because it wasn't supposed to happen the
top ranking democrat was supposed to
keep his seat this upstart truck driver
was not supposed to win and he did win
and now they're going to make up a bunch
of ballots and try to steal the election
this happens all the time a reminder
just a reminder as we look ahead to 2022
and 2024 and even as we discuss 2020
election fraud is old as time
lbj and fdr used to joke about it plenty
of elections have been stolen in this
country there's fraud to some degree in
every single election so we got to be
watching out for that sort of thing and
we can't let the democrats
bully us and tell us that if you ever
question the integrity of elections
you're promoting the big lie and you're
basically a nazi even though they don't
they don't even really understand that
the origin of the phrase the big lie
does go back to the nazis but it was
actually a line used by hitler and
accusing the jews of perpetrating a big
lie against a german general named eric
ludendorff and so actually if you accuse
someone of perpetrating the big lie
you're putting yourself in the position
of adolf hitler anyway the democrats
don't know any of that they're trying to
bully you they're trying to make you
seem like a nazi or white supremacist or
whatever don't do it there's always
going to be election fraud we need to be
really on guard against it because
the democrats are going to try to steal
elections they're trying to do it right
now in
new jersey we need to be
healthy
strong we've got to get all of our
affairs in order which if you've got
some problems you've been neglecting i
would strongly recommend you check out
roman when the moment for intimacy
arrives you need to be ready
roman ready whether you've been in a
relationship for years or are just
getting started having the confidence
that comes from preparation means you're
free to enjoy the moment when the moment
comes go to get roman.com knowles
canadawles right now to speak to a u.s
licensed healthcare professional about
erectile dysfunction and get 15 off your
first month of treatment
roman system is completely confidential
totally discreet no big logos or or or
labels on the packages with roman that
you can get a free online evaluation
ongoing care for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home
i know that sometimes guys don't want to
talk about this kind of stuff i i
understand it well roman makes it really
really easy to talk to a u.s licensed
healthcare professional who will work
with you to find the best treatment plan
ships with free two-day shipping the
whole process is straightforward
convenient and discreet go to
getroman.com slash knowles right now
if you're prescribed to get 15 off your
first month of ed treatment make sure
you are ready to have confidence and
control this fall roman ready what's
going on in new jersey right now is
you're seeing a conflict between
democracy and liberalism
okay
in the democracy
the voters in
this district of new jersey voted for a
republican truck driver over the
democrat president of the new jersey
state senate
more people voted for the truck driver
than voted for the corrupt democrat
so that's democracy
but liberalism says the democrats should
win because the democrat is on the side
of progress and the republican is on the
side of regress and he's on the wrong
side of history and he's not supposed to
win elections so you're seeing the
conflict right now between democracy and
liberalism and usually when when the
left refers to democracy they're really
referring to liberalism or progressivism
or leftism or there's obviously a lot of
overlap between all of those concepts
this is why when the majority of
americans vote for donald trump that's a
threat to our democracy right when
hillary clinton loses an election that's
a threat to our democracy when stacey
abrams loses an election that's a threat
to our democracy it's on the surface
it's not a threat to democracy more
people voted for the republican
but in the deeper sense it's
a threat to liberalism and the left
equates liberalism and democracy barack
obama did this yesterday at the u.n
climate summit
so barack obama can't keep his traps yet
so he flies over to to glasgow to give a
speech on global warming and he blames
unsurprisingly donald trump and
nationalism
for
global warming
back in the united states of course
some of our progress stalled when
my successor decided to unilaterally
pull out of the paris agreement in his
first year in office
i wasn't real happy about that
and yet
the determination
of our state and local governments
along with the regulations and
investment that my administration had
already put in place allowed our country
to keep moving forward
despite hostility from
the white house i recognize we're living
in a moment
when international cooperation has waned
a moment of greater geopolitical tension
and stress in part because of the
pandemic
in part because of the rise of
nationalism and
tribal impulses around the world
but there is one thing that should
transcend our day-to-day politics and
normal geopolitics and that is climate
change
there is so much in barack obama's
statement there
it's a bunch of lies
but then a really big secret truth
on the lies he says well donald trump's
fault that we're not meeting our
commitments we're not we're not doing
that because of my my successor that
that is not true here we have great
reporting from the daily wire reporting
on a great study that came out
in the statistical review of world
energy
shows u.s leading the world in reducing
carbon dioxide emissions
in the year after
the
election of donald trump we pull out of
the paris climate accord and yet we led
the world in reducing co2 emissions
much more so than
anyone else who actually remained signed
on to the paris thing so on the the
factual claim obama's making it's just
not true
but on the political claim
it shows you what this climate change
stuff is all about the climate change
stuff is about taking power it's about
taking power away from nations taking
power away from the people of nations
and giving it to
a global elite
he says it himself he says nationalism
is the problem
right again on the factual level it's
not donald trump pursued a course of
relative nationalism pulled out of the
global compact and he did better on
reducing carbon dioxide emissions than
all the other guys did obama kind of
acknowledges it when he says now look
now listen yeah sure the the numbers
kept going down and everything but uh
that's only because the businesses and
the locals and the states and the
communities kept listening to me
regardless of the motivation you're
still proving the
trump point you're still proving that
the nation
working on its own outside of this
transnational u.n compact
or paris climate agreement
can and and did do a better job than all
of the nations working in concert
for whatever reason maybe it's because
california just prefers to do it this
way maybe it's because
some company prefers to cut the inmate
but they still did it okay
but what
what obama says there at the end is the
key he says
if there's one issue that should
transcend our politics it's climate
change
what do you mean transcend our politics
you can't tran you can't transcend
politics when you're talking about
public questions politics and public
mean the same thing politics means
things that relate to public affairs
okay how we all live together
so what you're calling for is not
putting politics to the side you're
calling for a different kind of politics
whenever democrats say don't make this
political you can be dead certain they
are about to say something very very
political
and so what obama's really saying is
take your traditional political order
the traditional political order of
national sovereignty and
constitutionalism and the people
deciding how they want to live
and and trade that in for
globalism for internationalism for
having the u.n tell you how you're going
to live
that's if there's one issue that should
do it it's global warming and of course
it is
right that if you can really make the
claim that the world is about to end
unless we give up our sovereignty and
our political power to the un or
whatever global institution
then
then we'll we'll do it
if it's really an existential threat
we're all going to die in 12 years or 18
months or whatever they keep telling us
it is
now of course those doomsday predictions
which they've been making at least for
the last 50 years and actually much
further back than that those never come
true because it's not real because it's
a lie and it's a lie of demagogues to
steal your power away
and barack obama is doing it and he's
even acknowledging it if there's one
thing that should transcend our politics
it's global warming maybe that's the
reason that they keep harping on that
one thing even though their predictions
keep
failing
speaking of donald trump there's a poll
out that looks pretty good for donald
trump
npr pbs newshour marist poll 50
of republicans and right-leaning
independents believe that donald trump
has the best chance to win
in 2024 not just win the nomination
win the presidency
the the poll found that
35 of respondents want someone other
than trump
14
said they didn't yet know
so if you have the people who don't want
trump and the people who don't yet know
you add them together it's almost the
same as the number of people who think
that donald trump has the best shot of
winning the presidency
but the people who think trump has the
best shot still edged them out a little
bit
which is why
everyone now is moving on who's going to
be the nominee
is it going to be
desantis he's getting a lot of buzz
because of what he's doing in florida is
it going to be cruz is it going to be
hawley is it going to be
christy gnome is it she's kind of not
getting as much talk anymore is it going
to be nikki haley is it going to be you
know they keep floating all of these
names
but that and i like
at least most of those people
and i i'm friends actually with some of
those people
but the the question that you're going
to have to answer first is what is trump
going to do
what is trump going to do if trump gets
in
very likely he just clears the field
he's still got a ton of political
support
now
maybe it's good if trump runs maybe it's
not good if trump runs
maybe trump is going to blow it maybe
trump is a singular candidate maybe
people have had enough of trump maybe
trump didn't get to finish the job i
don't that's going to be debated
during the the primary or during a
pre-primary
when everyone's jockeying for position
but the one thing you can be sure of is
you should not count trump out yet he
still has a huge amount of influence and
even if he doesn't run
the numbers in this poll make it seem
like he sure could be the king maker and
there are a lot of republicans who don't
want trump to run
okay there is a
frank luntz who i think he was a never
trump republican he's he's more of the
centrist moderate wing of the republican
party he
for many years did those focus groups
where he'd go on sean hannity's show and
talk to 20 random people and
and say hey what did you think of the
debate and that was supposed to tell us
something about what the american people
thought i don't know it seemed a little
gimmicky to me but frank luntz has come
out big news he goes quote john carl
who's a left-wing journalist is about to
break a major story about trump
the gop
and january 20th that will embarrass a
lot of people
it's also in his new book john carl's
new book betrayal which isn't out yet
clue
it's been over 100 years since the
president of the united states did this
so we're all waiting with bated breath
what is it frank what's he what's he
going to reveal what did trump do
in his new book john carl reports that
trump actually quit the gop
before his plane took off on january
20th 2021.
he also will be the honoree at the house
gop gala tonight
does trump deny he quit the gop does
anyone deny this trump hold on you're
telling me the big shocking report
whether it's true or not i don't know
probably isn't true given the source but
you're saying the big shocking news the
bottom of the whole story is
donald
trump has a tense relationship with the
republican party no my gosh stop the
presses
no no you're who is supposed to be
shocked by this
all the people who love the gop no one
loves the gop that's why donald trump
was able to successfully lead a hostile
takeover of the gop
what planet are these people living on
these p you know these people
they might not be the brightest bulbs
in the pack okay they might not be the
sharpest tools in the shed they might
not even understand that they could
refinance their mortgage right now and
save a lot of money if you want to do
that i recommend you check out american
financing the year may be coming to a
close but there is still time to make a
positive impact on your budget before
year end mortgage rates remain near
money saving lows now you might be
thinking why why my mortgage is fine as
it is
well what you should be asking is how
can my mortgage work for me that answer
can be found at american financing
america's home for home loans they don't
pressure you
instead their salary based mortgage
consultants get to know you so they can
lead you to greater overall savings it
could be a shorter loan term it could be
consolidating debt because there is more
to a refinance than just a lower rate
and it's the reason why they save
customers up to a thousand dollars a
month
why not see what they can do for you
call 800-685-5696
that number is
800-685-5696 or if you're digitally
inclined visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 and
mls consumeraccess.org
it's been nearly a week since the daily
wire filed a lawsuit against the federal
government while it is an unprecedented
move for the daily wire we don't see any
other option okay we are not going to
give in to joe biden's unconstitutional
mandate the daily wires lawsuit was
filed by the dillon law group and
alliance defending freedom in the u.s
court of appeals for the sixth circuit
the lawsuit alleges that the biden
administration lacks constitutional and
statutory authority to issue the
employer mandate that the mandate failed
to meet the requirements for issuing a
rule taking effect immediately without
the normal process of considering public
comments and the biden administration
has warned that any companies that do
not comply with this federal overreach
could be fined as much as
136
000
per violation
per violation which is something pretty
much no company could cover certainly
not in the long run that's why we need
your help if you are not a member yet
please consider joining us today if you
go to dailywire.com subscribe and enter
code do not comply at checkout you will
receive 25 off your membership and you
you'll be fighting this unconstitutional
mandate with us we appreciate your help
we will not comply that's dailywire.com
subscribe code do not comply for 25 off
also
tomorrow night you can catch a new
episode of backstage where we discuss
the turning of the tide join me ben
shapiro jeremy boring matt walsh andrew
clavin at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central on
dailywire.com
and our youtube channel daily wire and
one more thing before we go
we're launching daily wire now which
means you'll be able to stream all your
favorite daily wire shows on vizio
smartcast tune in to watch candace
discuss current events with trump with
dana white with all sorts of people tune
in to watch yours truly
uh there is always something interesting
to stream daily wire now exclusively on
vizio's watch free plus streaming app on
channel 162 to access the content you
love 24 hours a day 7 days a week we'll
be right back with a lot more
the republican party can't win for
losing the republican party as ever
seems dead set on clutching
defeat from the jaws of victory these
people have no idea what's going on
i can't get over it
i cannot get over it
what just happened in virginia
virginia
we took this governor's race that by all
rights we should have lost
virginia is a very blue commonwealth
terry mcauliffe had a big organization
there
and we we won virginia
by focusing on education
by focusing on real culture war type
issues
the radical racial theories being taught
in schools
the radical sexual theories being taught
in schools
the transgender bathroom policies
that allowed a boy in a in a skirt to go
in and rape a girl in a girl's bathroom
in
virginia in loudoun county
that's what that's what won us the race
right wing
culture war issues
that talk about the kooky theories on
race and sex
being pushed by the left so what does
the gop do well the gop the republican
party just announced heading into the
midterms
a new pride coalition
a pride coal an lgbt
coalition
you win a race
you rent out you rent a race in virginia
by running against transgenderism
and the first thing you do is start a
transgender coalition for the gop
can we just dissolve the party now can
we start a new is there a new party we
can i can join
no i'm not going to join the libertarian
party give me a break
no i'm not going to do i don't even know
what the other ones are no i guess i
guess not for now i guess we just need
to
fire the people working at the gop the
rnc
and put serious people in their place
by the way this is not to say i don't
think gay people should vote for
republicans i think they should
many of my dearest friends are gay
republicans all right but they're not
they're not pride republicans they're
not pro what do i mean by that i mean
there are all sorts of people who have
all sorts of unusual
desires and sorts of things it's a very
diverse world
i would say most of the people who
identify as gay or bisexual or lesbian
or transgender or whatever
they they tend to go
democrat right they tend to lean left
there are some who do not go democrat
the ones who are not voting for
democrats are the ones for whom their
sexual desires are not the be all and
end-all of their identity
they have deeper foundations of their
identity as well and their sexual
desires are a complicating factor for
that and there may be an aspect of their
identity but they're not the basic thing
we are never ever going to win over
people for whom sexual identity politics
forms the essence of their being it's it
cannot happen
because it is
intrinsically
leftist
it is intrinsically not conservative
for your sexual desire to be the
foundation of your identity
so there might be a fella
who's sexually attracted to other fellas
but he votes republican because
he
thinks about god
he
reveres
founding fathers he likes sound economic
policy he
wants to pursue american interests on
the world stage
over other interests
and those things are just much much
bigger for him
than who who he is attracted to
pride pride goeth before destruction and
a haughty spirit before a fall goodness
gracious people
pride we're running on now
this is the rnc
the people who run the rnc
they they seem to be democrats from four
or five years ago
and i wouldn't even say democrats from
10 years ago democrats 10 years ago
wouldn't run on pride
democrats 10 years ago believed that
marriage was a sacred bond between a man
and a woman
barack obama said that hillary clinton
said that so they're not even democrats
ten years ago they're democrats five
years ago because they don't believe in
a damn thing
it is so and worse than that i mean you
can just say well they're just
cynical opportunistic politicians but
they're not even smart about it
not
not one single vote will be won by a
republican party pride coalition
not one vote
all of the people with
eclectic unusual sexual desires who are
going to vote for republicans
are going to vote for republicans for
other reasons
now a pride coalition might turn off a
lot of voters who think that there's
really no difference between the
democrats and the republicans and
they've got good reason to think that
but you're not going to just as a
tactical political operation you're not
going to win a single vote
leave it to the rnc to try to clutch
defeat from the jaws of victory it's so
pathetic
now there's one counter argument here
okay the counter argument as to why the
gop needs an lgbt pride coalition
is that the country is turning super
duper gay super duper fast
okay and this is this is backed up by
some social scientific data so there's a
survey out from arizona christian
university
that shows
that 39
almost two out of every five 18 to 24
year olds in the united states
identify as lgbtq
two in five young americans
say that they're gay
but
they're not okay they're not you're not
i'm sorry you're not you're not that
interesting you're not that special
you're not
you're just confused and i don't even
mean to be this harsh to the nearly 40
of young americans who insist that
they're part of the alphabet soup but
you're not you're just a young person
you're you're human sexuality and human
desire is a complex thing and you need
to get over yourself okay the
what this says to me
from a political standpoint
is something that we all should have
known for a very long time namely that
lgbt the whole
sexual identity alphabet soup
they are not oppressed
on the contrary
that there is a certain privilege that
goes along with identifying as
lgbtq
there is a social currency that goes
along with that that this is just basic
incentives that is why more and more
people
are identifying that way unless you're
going the alex jones route and you
believe that they're just putting
something in the water that's turning
the frickin zoomers gay then you i think
you need to recognize there is a social
contagion aspect to this
that people are being incentivized to
identify this way and it makes perfect
sense
it goes back to the kyle rittenhouse
thing the worst possible thing you can
possibly be in society today is a
straight white male you are the you were
the incarnation of evil if you were a
straight white male
you are told that straight white males
are the most privileged people in the
country the reality is you are the least
privileged person in the country at
least according to the law and at least
according to the new prevailing social
norms
you're a terrible person you should be
disadvantaged in college admissions you
should be disadvantaged in the job
search you should be segregated out of
certain social spaces
but if you can if you're let's say
you're a white guy
and you think gosh i'm i'm awful how do
i how do i make myself
seem oppressed and therefore thereby
paradoxically become privileged well you
would identify as
lgbt or whatever
being lgbt is cool and hip and trendy
and it's the the official state religion
right the the
metaphysical claims of lgbt especially
the tea party namely that your body has
nothing to do with who you really are
is
that is now officially pushed by the
state it's pushed in the schools it's
pushed everywhere throughout our society
so you can either go along with that or
you can be a heretic if you're a
christian or a jew or a muslim or you
you just hold a basically aristotelian
view of human nature and sexuality
you're a heretic
away from the state religion
what's funny is there's the other side
of this which is the lgb part of it
which says that you basically are only
your body that you're you know the tea
part says you're not your body at all
you're only this kind of spirit and the
lgb part says you're basically only your
body you're born this way whatever your
sexual desires are you have to follow
them you have to pursue them to their
logical conclusion and you basically
have no right to control or rein those
things in because that would be
repressive and repression is really bad
so it's incoherent but the the one view
they don't hold is that we're
body and soul and spirit right that
we're both of these things physical and
metaphysical
the reason i mentioned the silly survey
is uh
is political though
the reason i mention it
is we ought to use this knowledge to our
own advantage
we as conservatives
we ought to use the knowledge
that people can be easily swayed even
about a
increasingly important aspect of their
identity
by prevailing social winds
i promise you
if tomorrow it became less cool to
identify as transgender or whatever
fewer people would do it
if it carried less social currency less
privilege
less legal advantage in some cases fewer
people would do it
and that's how things were before and
now now it carries
all great sort all of these sorts of
privileges and advantages so more people
are doing that too
contrary to
i guess more the libertarian right what
they have said
the the politics the government actually
can shape the culture and can shape
people's identities and the way that
social mores and standards and taboos
and things like that evolve
and kids are being taught this stuff in
school i mean it's no surprise that
after being taught in school that
straight white guys are evil and being
taught critical race theory and being
transgender ideology and being taught
this for many years at this point that
more and more students would identify in
accordance with those beliefs and
meanwhile the left is denying that those
things are being taught in schools in
the first place rick scott just went on
cnn he was talking to one of the cnn
ladies her name is
brianna kyler and but she's just one of
the sort of interchangeable automatons
on cnn and he mentioned the importance
of critical race theory to this to this
race that we just saw in virginia and
the cnn lady interrupts to say beep boop
beep boop critical race theory is not
being taught in schools
parents know it's been their kids are
being indoctrinated with critical race
theory in virginia and the democrats
wanted to deny it and so well it's not
in the corrections showed up because
they don't like the intelligence i mean
just just to be clear it's not it's not
in the curriculum
um in virginia but just just
like me here let me just read you a few
things just in 2015 while terry
mcauliffe was governor the virginia
department of education promoting
incorporating a critical race theory
lens in education you can still find it
on the department of education's website
still there
in february
for the virginia 2019 of education
promoting crucial race theory and the
idea of white fragility it's not it's
not
part of the question
i do want to ask you
just to be clear
about where you are let's all agree
they were trying to indoctrinate kids
terry mcauliffe denied it it's still on
the website
it is this is happening
and i hope democrats continue to say
it's not happening because parents are
dumb
they can see it your parents are dumb
you said aren't dumb
no they're not
i think parents are smart
okay well it's not being and she goes on
by the way she keeps going and she goes
it's not it's not being taught in
schools okay we just need and he kind of
leaves it there and then they move on
it's not no it's not it's not being
taught it's not being taught in schools
then he reads from the
virginia department of education website
where it lays out exactly how critical
race theory is being taught in schools
and what does she do does she admit that
she was wrong
does she no she goes uh uh
glitch
you can see like the smoke is starting
to come out of her ears she goes no it
doesn't does not compute
critical race theory is not in the
curriculum
no um but uh brianna the hearing i'm
just reading you it says uh from the
virginia state department of education
uh the critical race theory is totally
being taught in the curriculum dot com
right it's just like exactly from the
website uh but
does not no critical race theory beep
boop beep boop and they can't do it they
have no answer to that because
she obviously got a talking point from
her bosses at cnn to say at all
turns deny the critical race theory is
being taught in schools
and unfortunately she was not prepared
with the evidence that it is being
taught in schools and that's what the
whole race was about the best she can
muster at the end is what you
did you just say parents are dumb hahaha
and he goes no no i said the opposite of
that again once again it's the opposite
of what you're saying
that it is but keep it up keep it up
democrats keep it up because they don't
because they don't know what we think
they don't know how to respond to the
points that we make and sometimes that
ends in disaster for them as it just did
in that virginia governor's race
speaking of woke indoctrination
there is a new
there is a new university
being founded here in the united states
university
of austin
the university of austin is being pushed
by barry weiss former new york times
writer who is now off on her own
she was not sufficient she is a liberal
but she wasn't sufficiently woke for the
new york times so now she has a sub
stack and her sub stack is frankly much
more interesting than anything put out
by the new york times headline we can't
wait for universities to fix themselves
so we're starting a new one i left my
post as president of saint john's
college in annapolis oh that well this
is a post from uh uh pono canilos who
was president of st john's college in
annapolis uh to build a university in
austin dedicated to the fearless pursuit
of truth
and
uh
they go on and it's you know it's an
interesting
manifesto here to say that uh you know
universities are are extremely
uh left-wing now and extremely woke and
there's not freedom of speech on campus
and freedom of inquiry
they're right in these top schools and
in so many others can we actually claim
that the pursuit of truth once the
central purpose of a university remains
the highest virtue do we honestly
believe that the crucial means to that
end freedom of inquiry and civil
discourse prevail when ill-liberalism
has become a pervasive feature of campus
life so they go on and they say you know
this is bad
uh people are being treated like thought
criminals there's a lot of
sensoriousness which actually doesn't
mean what people think it means people
think sensoriousness means
censorship
and that to be sensorious is to be the
sort of person who censors someone but
it's actually not it means to be harshly
critical uh so anyway
it comes up it turns out that fear can
become endemic in a free society this is
very uh oppressive and that universities
are supposed to defend quote the right
to think the unthinkable discuss the
unmentionable and challenge the
unchallengeable okay so
so what they are founding right now
is a liberal university and these words
get really confusing because we talk
about liberal education
but that's not the same thing as a
liberal university like liberal
education and the liberal arts is not
the same thing as liberalism
liberal education and
and uh liberal the liberal arts
uh those are phrases that are really
popularized in the 11th century 12th
century 13th century
these are
phrases that and that actually have
roots in antiquity
that refer to the
the things that you need to know to be
free to make sense of your freedom
you are educated to become a free
person
if we're not educated then we're just
slaves to our own appetites and desires
and all we do all day is shoot up drugs
and stuff our faces and get drunk and
have sex but if you if you study the
liberal arts and you become
uh
educated in this liberal way you will
be able to tame down all of those
passions you will cultivate the mind you
will you will cultivate all the deepest
truths
that your civilization has uncovered and
you will become a free person and a
rational person and able to control
yourself
liberalism is an ideology that developed
during the enlightenment and liberalism
is a
sort of rationalist ideology that you
know branches off in lots of different
directions but it posits certain rights
and certain forms of government and
we're living in in the world that
liberalism created they're not the same
thing
and so
how would i distinguish between the two
liberal like liberal education liberal
arts is focused as these guys say
untruth right there is a certain truth
and you we need to pursue that truth and
some things are right and some things
are wrong and if you put the wrong
answer down you're going to get punished
and if you put the right answer down
you're going to get rewarded with good
grades
liberalism as an ideology pursues lots
of other things like um free speech
absolutism or like academic freedom this
idea that you should be able to say and
and
preach whatever you want in the
university everyone should have the
right to speak in the university that's
not a particularly conservative opinion
and i fear what's going to happen with
the this university the university of
austin is that it's going to devolve
into the in the same way that the other
universities have in our country
because freedom academic freedom is a
hoax it's bs i mean the conservative
movement was founded with a book making
fun of academic freedom
you actually shouldn't have total
academic freedom at a university you
shouldn't a nazi should not be able to
teach your sociology class a communist
should not be able to teach your
economics classes
the point of the university is bringing
together all of these disciplines and
pointing toward truth and unfortunately
there is a reason that the university is
created by the catholic church
there is a reason that the university is
invented
within christendom at the highest point
of christendom and then it kind of just
starts to collapse as christianity fades
away from our culture because you need
a unity of truth you need a monopoly on
truth you need to be able to say this is
true and this is false and we are not
going to teach these ideas and we are
only going to teach these ideas and
they're going to lead towards something
the idea of truth pursuing truth
fearlessly and the idea of academic
freedom
are actually kind of opposites they
don't really go together that well
because truth says that there is
objective reality and academic the
academic freedom ideology says that
everything's kind of relative and we
need to hear everybody out but you
actually don't to quote bill buckley
skepticism has utility only when it
leads to conviction so
i don't want to be too down on this
effort they've got some conservatives
and a lot of it is just kind of
classical liberal types but but they've
got some conservatives involved so rob
amari is involved you know some pretty
serious conservatives um so i wish them
well i don't i don't really mean to
criticize they're getting enough
criticism from the left and i really
hope this thing goes well but they are
going to have to resolve that tension
okay and they are going to have to
choose
are they going to be a university
that just pursues the liberal ideology
academic freedom relativism subjectivism
or are they going to say no some things
are true and some things are false and
we're going to teach the true stuff and
we're going to kick out the false stuff
speaking of good and bad and right and
wrong we've only got about a minute left
but i really want to get to this story
uh the travis scott story you know a
bunch of people were killed at a travis
scott concert eight people were killed
between the ages of 14 and 27 as young
as 14 which really makes you ask i mean
it's a horrible tragedy it does make you
ask why was a 14 year old at this kind
of concert with this
this filth and this demonic imagery and
why were they there i don't know i mean
i fee i've i went to concerts when i was
14 and 15 and so i i mean i really
really feel for these parents and
everything but
the concert was run very poorly there
were way too many people in there it was
very unsafe
uh there's there are these theories
coming around that this was some kind of
demonic sacrifice or something i think
that's probably a little extreme as well
but one thing we can't deny is there are
demonic symbols here okay travis scott
was wearing a t-shirt of people walking
through a portal and turning into demons
the motto for the show would see you on
the other side the the uh one of the
entrances was a gigantic mouth that
looked like the garden of earthly
delights painting by uh hieronymus bosch
okay yesterday satanic panic was
trending this idea that you know oh no
everyone's worried about satan like they
were in the 80s and 90s first of all you
shouldn't panic about satan but you
should reject satan and all his works
and all his empty promises and
furthermore i listen i had never heard
of travis scott i listened to some of
his music i watched some of his videos
and it's it's filth i mean it's just
degenerate filth and if you listen to it
you are going to degrade yourself and
there's just there's just no reason to
listen to it and so
there's a lot of blame i'm sure to go
around here
of the people who put the concert on the
security staff maybe the guy himself
travis scott but this is really bad
stuff this is an ugly culture this is an
ugly culture that gins up all of the
worst kind of bass passions great
writers have been talking about this
since antiquity it's got all this sort
of ugly satanic imagery kind of like
a little nas x
and uh so if there's if the argument now
is that well all these bad vicious evil
terrible demonic things they're just
being used ironically or they're just
being used kind of in jest or something
well the fact is if you behave
ironically for your whole life then
there's no difference between that and
behaving sincerely really really
terrible story all around
regardless of
how exactly this is going to shake out
on who is responsible for what
don't listen to travis scott this is bad
stuff it's gonna decay your mind and
your soul and your culture
bad stuff all around okay we need we
need we need higher things we need
higher things pursue the good avoid the
evil i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode more details emerge
on the fatal travis scott concert the
latest from the kyle rittenhouse trial
and texas changes its constitution to
combat restrictive covet policies
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire